mr. secretary thank you very much of the
time I've got a lot to ask you about
including your trip to Asia what's going
on in Ukraine but let me start first
with what happened at Fort Hood the
tragedy there you have any better idea
why ivan lopez opened fire on his fellow
American soldiers and why this is
happening so often well it is a terrible
tragedy and it's been revisited once
again on Fort Hood so our thoughts and
our prayers go out to the families of
the victims and those who have been
wounded and we're going to continue to
focus on them as we should but in the
meantime let the investigators do their
work we don't have a lot of the answers
we don't know why it happened we don't
know why he did what he did we will find
that out but this is 24 hours away from
that terrible incident so we're working
very hard assure first of all the safety
on all of our bases of our men and women
who worked there every day and and their
families so that they're reassured but
we'll find out what does it say sir that
America's military men and women are
finding themselves in harm's way back
here at home as well well it's a it's a
terrible statement I recognize that we
all do but like anything you we've got
to figure out what happened and what
went wrong we've been adjusting to and
implementing a number of recommendations
that came out of the 2009 Fort Hood
incident to mavey yard incident last
year to further bring more security and
further security to our bases and we'll
see what comes out of this as to how do
we assure in every way possible
the safety and security of those
those bases you've been meeting with ten
of your Southeast Asian counterparts are
going on to Japan China Mongolia you've
said and just told us here this is again
a sign of the commitment to the
rebalance to the Asia Pacific from the
Obama administration my question for you
sir is given what's happening in Ukraine
Syria American troops still in
Afghanistan is this really the right
time to rebalance towards Asia well I
don't think you can develop your
strategic interests based on one episode
or two episodes strategic interests are
driven by a nation's national interests
we've been a Pacific Power for many many
years a significant Pacific Power the
three largest economies in the world
border the Pacific China Japan the
United States we have treaty obligations
here we have some of our strongest
allies in this area we have tremendous
the important interests security
stability economic diplomatic interests
in this area so it's not a matter either
of choosing which part of the world
we're going to be in and which part of
the world we're not going to be in we're
not retreating for any part of the world
we have 400,000 men and women deployed
stationed all over the world in a
hundred countries were strong in NATO
we're going to continue to be the Middle
East but this is an area that is very
important to America and for our future
and for the Chinese and you're gonna be
mean your first trip is secretary to
China now you've been there before in
the past why shouldn't they take this
rebalance as a direct threat
well we've assured them in every way
President Obama has in his recent
meeting with President Xi mrs. Obama
being in China I have secretary Kerry
all of our administration's that this is
not a contained China approach this is
an approach to reach out to try to be
more open communique coordinate find
ways that we can work with each other in
a common purpose in common interests we
do that now with the Chinese and
areas will continue to do that do we
have differences yes we have differences
but the only way to deal with that is to
be direct open and I was invited to come
by the Minister of Defense I'm looking
forward to being there for three days
and talking about all these areas of
possible new cooperation and we'll talk
about where we differ as well let me ask
is you're on your way to Asia we still
have tensions in Europe the crisis in
Ukraine does not feel like we're
de-escalating at this point maybe the
opposite what's your sense right now
what evidence do you have if any that
the Russians those troops along the
Ukrainian border are backing down in any
way we're heading home we do not have
any verification that they are pulling
troops back there and then various
reports that they are moving troops back
there are troops that are moving around
we know that but no indication of any
significant movement of those large
troop deployments along that border away
from the border but the president's been
focused on a diplomatic resolution we
want to de-escalate this in every way we
can that's the smart way to do it the
responsible way to do it the Europeans
are coalescing now completely the EU
NATO around this effort and we made it
very clear what our position is here so
I think this is the responsible approach
and we'll continue to work at it it
feels like though that NATO may be
ratcheting things up you're sending
another US warship into the Black Sea
there's talk about NATO again
considering more options to sort of
reinforce the position in Eastern Europe
even the idea sort of maybe returning
one brigade and US Army Brigade back to
Europe that's been at least floated as
an idea could we do that would that be
something the Defense Department the the
US would consider sending an army we
gave back permanently to Europe well as
you know our European commanders supreme
Allied commander general Breedlove has
been tasked by NATO to come back to NATO
in about a week with a number of new
possibilities new measures new options
that we and NATO should consider and can
consider and and those areas that are
well are all part of the measures that
that could be considered but well let's
wait to see what general Breedlove comes
back with do you get a sense are you
worried this is getting gonna become
worse before it gets better
no I don't think there's any escalation
on our part we told the Russians there
would be consequences for their actions
we've taken economic sanctions the EU
the United United States and so we've
been very clear what measures we would
take the Obama administration misjudge
Vladimir Putin and the challenge posed
by Russia going forward I don't think
anybody misjudged
light of our Putin unless let's go back
to 2008 when President Putin invaded
Georgia so this isn't a particularly new
approach that he's taken but what you
always have to do is you have to always
be prepared for any contingencies any
possibilities but I don't think it was a
matter of a misjudging Putin what his
intentions were why he did what he did
we we still don't understand fully but
the point of responsible governments is
to have strong options and capabilities
and be prepared for any contingency it's
a dangerous world out there and it's a
very unpredictable world and you're
having to negotiate that at an
environment of dwindling defence dollars
of tough budgets you just presented one
as the situation in Ukraine the the
crisis there
led you to reassess even the budget you
just submitted would you do things
differently now knowing what's happening
well let's not forget the number that I
presented in the president's budget was
not my number was that the president's
number that was that was a number that
was already agreed to by Congress
in the bipartisan Budget agreement in
December
so the 496 billion dollar budget
you've already already we've already
presented a bigger number the budget
that I presented President Obama's
budget was a bigger number and we've
asked for a hundred and sixteen billion
dollars more than what the numbers are
right now based on sequestration in the
next two years and for this year a
twenty six billion dollar increase in
the budget as well so does President
Obama have made that very clear as I
have does this crisis in some strange
way make your case for you that these
numbers need to be higher could you the
Ukraine crisis the challenge posed by
Russia ultimately helped Chuck Hagel get
the kind of budget you want well I think
the way you look at it is not just one
episode but what is it going to take to
fulfill the missions and obligations of
our Defense Department budget in order
to assure the security of the United
States of America we have weeks of
continued testimony we've got senior
members today up on Capitol Hill
explaining to the Congress what we need
in the way of resources in order to
fulfill those missions to assure the
United States the people of the United
States that we can do the job that they
want us to do to assure of their
security so we believe it's going to
take increased resources we've laid that
out we've given the numbers and we've
given the rise now you're on your waiter
[ __ ] you're the first defense secretary
to go there since Don Rumsfeld about ten
years ago when he got there what he left
they gave him a gift of a horse my
question is are you prepared for a
similar gift and is there room on the
plane well I don't know if my guys would
consider give me a horse but I would be
privileged if if they give me any
recognition of our partnership the
United States and Mongolia but probably
there's no place for livestock that I've
seen on that plane